Tonight is movie night.
In here is the great big world.
You can go places
your dreams can't dream up.
Or see things that give
your nightmares nightmares.
Hallelujah!
In here, you can make your escape.
I already don't like you.
Right back at you, sunshine.
In here, mystery sparks
extraordinary adventure.
The real mystery is
why everyone's talking to them.
I thought that was my thing.
In here, you never know
where the road will take you.
Drive!
When you walk on that court,
you have to think,
I am the best guy out there.
I don't care if LeBron's playing.
In here, the party never stops.
That's false! I got something to do
in the morning, so it kinda does.
-You filming this?
-Kinda.
-You don't have to.
-I know. I'm doing it for me.
Okay.
In here, you can make
an incredible discovery.
Or feel like a kid again.
Wanna see something cool?
In here is the great big world.
And every night is movie night.